welcome everyone today at a bit of an
unusual location we are in london as i
guess you can see here based on the
buses we are currently here on and off
site with building raider next to me is
leopold who is managing director and
founder of building raider he is also a
former school friend of mine worked at
google among other companies before it's
looking forward now to go actually to a
wework to meet a couple of other
colleagues from the building raider team
we have a little team that is based here
in london i trust we are going to spend
a few very productive insightful days
here and i will bring you along of what
is happening what we are doing so we are
on our way to the we work i actually
love the city because i spent one year
here in london school of economics for a
master and at the wework our chief
product officer was already waiting for
us reworks are i think always an
interesting experience some pros and
cons of working in a co-working space
like that for our use case it definitely
was great to sit together with some
colleague of us we were one of the first
people here in the we work today at
lunch you went to chinatown i always
loved the chinatown in london this
vibrant radiating atmosphere a good
friend of us who has also chinese
background recommended us a really nice
lunch place it was amazing food actually
also quite affordable so definitely very
much worth attending so afterwards you
had some additional time to explore the
area my wife was actually with me as
well together with our baby girl
actually later this year we are
expecting our second baby our second
child so exciting times for us for sure
and afterwards we headed back to the
rework to get some additional work done
we're debating some new features that we
want to launch for building radar
platform we realized that we all have
slightly different ideas of how these
were supposed to look like so we figured
let's just take a sheet of paper let's
just draw down what we have in our minds
to then compare this and this was quite
an effective exercise this time we also
moved to slightly different area of the
wework which was a little bit quieter a
little bit more for ourselves and this
led to i think a quite productive
session with lots of ideation happening
together with our london-based
colleagues afterwards we did something
that i missed quite a lot and this is
enjoying the london pop culture so we
met in one of the traditional london
pubs enjoyed a nice beer and had just a
very good time in january after that of
course we also visited lse london school
of economics university where i did my
master they did upgrade the university
facilities quite significantly since i
was there then the other day we went
back there just also to explore the
campus by day currently graduations were
going on so congrats to everyone who
recently graduated from lse i found the
academic experience to be reasonably
challenging so this is definitely very
very much deserved in the master program
i focus on accounting and finance and
the knowledge that i acquired during
this year definitely helped me on almost
every single project afterwards in
consulting at mckinsey so for me this
experience was definitely worth it and
also quite a lot of fun indeed
afterwards you're invited by some
friends who are working as barristers in
london to have lunch at a very special
location definitely enjoyed this one and
then the next day on the weekend we went
to some parks in london this is
piccadilly circus actually very close to
where the mckinsey office at least used
to be in london we had an amazing time
there are some areas in london where you
feel like actually not in london at all
but that seemed to be more like munich
or some place like that so i definitely
enjoyed myself also being there with my
family and then afterwards you also had
the opportunity to visit a good friend
who lived in the new better sea real
estate development this is a very new
real estate development project with
some amazing living units that are being
created there also completely different
experience compared what you're usually
used to in london i hope you enjoyed
these impressions leave a like if you
did big big thanks to all the members as
well my name is heinrich in weekly
content see you again next week